Now we turn our attention to the Transport layer, which
sits between the Network layer and the Application layer. The
key contribution of this layer, is the notion of ports,
which tells the OS which process the data is intended for.
On a Linux machine, you can see this mapping using
LSOF-I. Having multiple ports allows more than one application to
receive data from the network at once, something called multiplex.
Port numbers are 16 bits long, and many of them are
reserved for special purposes. Port 80, for instance, is
typically the one used for receiving HTTP requests, like a
browser would send. In fact, we'll use this as an
example. Let's say we're running Chrome, and that we visit
the Udacity homepage. Then Chrome will ask the operating system
for a port number that it can use, or it'll
pick one that has been allocated already. Let's say the
port number is 55804. It sends, then sends the request
in a packet with a source port of 55804 and
a destination port of 80. When the Udacity server responds,
it will send back a packet whose destination port matches
the one that we sent. That way, the OS will know
to route the packet to Chrome, and not to some
other program. It is important to realize that the transport
layer is really only active at the end points at
the route. The intermediate routers on the internet need only look
at the IP address to know where to forward the
packet to. So they never examine the port number. Control starts
at the Application layer, moves through the Transport layer and
the Network layer and the Link layer and the Physical layer.
At the first node. Then through these intermediate steps, of
course, we need to interpret the signal. Pull off any sort
of ethernet frame, or the like. And then look at the
IP packet to figure out where the packet should go next.
We never need to look inside the IP packet at whatever comes in the
transport layer. And then forward it and
the same thing happens in the next node,
and then only when we receive it do we need to. Unpack the transport
layer. Route it to the correct application,
and then let the application interpret the data.